my name is kate gerwin my bar in
albuquerque new mexico is called happy
accidents and we are nominated for best
american cocktail bar and i'm going to
make for you my favorite cocktail which
is a
neat pour of mezcal
[Music]
people ask me all the time they're like
what do you do and i'm like i'm a
bartender and they're like oh no you're
an entrepreneur you're a business owner
i'm like i'm a bartender i don't want to
be called anything else i love my
industry i love my people i love what i
do i still want to be behind the bar i'm
still behind the bar on fridays and
saturdays i still want to see that smile
on people's faces there's nothing better
than what we do
for me
we're independently owned we're
bartender owned we have
no big backers no pr firm we are a
distillery bar as well
and you know i don't really believe that
we were nominated you know specifically
for our cocktails i think we were
nominated for the ethos behind our
company which is mostly that staff comes
first the people who work for us make us
they are who
we are and we put them as a priority in
everything that we do
our staff makes a living wage they all
get health insurance and you know
eventually they can get partnership in
our company and if not and they want to
go on and open their own we hope that
one day we'll be able to invest in all
of our employees and help them you know
make their dreams come true as well the
industry has
notoriously been very difficult
people have
worked to survive
and you know thriving isn't really
something that happens for a lot of
hospitality workers and i think
as soon as we make our staff a priority
we can change the way that our industry
functions
part of it was seeing that
my people suffer during covid you know i
saw my friends and people i consider my
family
were kind of just withering away and
everyone was doing the pivot dance you
know what can i do with my life now
i'm in my 40s i didn't want to pivot
so it was really important to me to
make it a priority to
prioritize my staff and make sure that
they never had to go through that again
our business model is a distillery bar
we have a craft distillers license so um
our
profits are a little bit different you
know we get our spirits in bulk
we blend
and we go into our own bottles we don't
have we have a great sustainability
platform we don't have bottle waste but
that also enables us to operate a
different profit margin and
that was really important in
prioritizing our staff with health
insurance and making sure that everybody
has access to a living wage in you know
our state of new mexico the average
living wage income is like 34 000 and
you know my bartenders
well make well over double that
they're living the life that they should
be living and it's just really important
that hospitality industry people
know that this career is viable
and that you can have fun and it doesn't
have to be something that you're doing
until you do something else this can be
the end goal if you just prioritize it
[Applause]
[Music]